The question is, Hey, Americans and David,
what the F is wrong with you?
I live in the UK and I see you vote in this
idiot.
Trump are U people this stupid.
He's obviously a criminal every which way
and you can't remove him and Republicans don't
want to seriously what is wrong with your
country?
The world is laughing.
You know?
This is interesting for a few reasons.
It's interesting, number one, because there
are a lot of Trumpists who when they see that
attitude from someone in the UK about what
we're doing here about Trump being president,
they're emboldened in some way.
They see that and they say, Oh, these stupid
sissy Europeans don't like what Trump is doing.
It's because he's doing what's good for America.
He's making America great again.
Who cares if they don't like what Trump's
doing?
It's good.
Some even believe that they don't like what
Trump's doing because it's not good for them.
It's good for us and unfortunately those are
not people that can be reasoned with and I
shared this sympathy.
I share these sentiments.
I sympathize with this perspective.
When I travel to Europe and talk to my friends
or family in the UK or in France, or when
I talk to my cousins in Israel, uh, who are
not right-wingers, or when I talk to my family
in Argentina, um, or friends in Italy, for
example, in Canada, nobody really understands
what's going on there.
Number one, feeling that they come to me with
his explain not just how this happened because
okay, we can sort of understand there was
like a racist reaction to Obama.
There was dislike of Hillary.
There was Trump bamboozling people into them
thinking that he is that the outsider guy
who's gonna, you know, economic anxiety, preying
on people's fear of losing status or perceived
status.
They get all that.
But it's been two and a half years now.
It's been two and a half years.
How is everybody not against the sky?
And what you need to understand is that everybody
will never be against the sky.
And I don't know if it's 20, 25, 28 ish percent
of the voting public that is never, ever,
ever going to abandon the sky.
They will never be convinced to say, you know
what?
I was wrong.
Some people have been convinced in that way.
I've taken phone calls from some of those
people, but there's this hardcore base that
will never be convinced.
So my answer to you is that this is a combination
of hyper partisanship, but that's too benign
and that doesn't include any kind of culpability
in it.
Okay?
It's hyper partisanship.
It's cognitive dissonance.
It is also to use your term, it is stupidity
in the sense that a lot of people just lack
information.
They are in their echo chamber filter bubble.
They never hear about half of what's going
on.
And when they do, they have been primed to
write it off as fake news.
So we are in trouble.
I know the world is laughing.
I don't like that the world is laughing and
it actually hurts us that the world is laughing.
But if you're waiting for that hardcore base
of 2020 to 25 28% whatever the number is to
come to their senses, don't hold your breath
because you're gonna, you're gonna end up
without oxygen to breathe.
Quite frankly.